hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the benefits of combining
optogenetics microscopy and
electrophysiology presented by dr.
Durant wild i'm doing a child of
leopards and i'll be a moderator for
today's presentation very excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by libraries the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning this webinar is sponsored by
under technology under technology is
based in belfast northern ireland and
upwards that a high value and the of the
global scientific digital camera market
under was set up in 1989 out of please
University in Belfast and now includes
over 400 people in 16 offices worldwide
and distributes products to 10,000
customers of 55 countries for more
information please go to endure calm
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting any questions as many
questions as you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as you have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be hearing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge laurindo just
click on the screen icon located a
number lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation in go
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem this is an
educational webinar and thus offering
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
sweetie pie and milk ad on the bottom
left hand corner of your web page page
and then follow the process of obtaining
your credits now I would like to
introduce Bryant wild dr. Wilde studied
pharmacology at the University of Leeds
book
receiving to postgraduate studies at the
University of Southampton after
attaining a PhD in 1997 dr. Wilde
continuing his interest in neuroscience
with the postdoctoral position at the
University of Warwick following this
post's you then moved to the University
of Liverpool to work in the laboratory
home professor Michael White focusing on
intracellular signaling gene expression
gene expression through live cell
imaging dr. Rogers microscopy the most
of his research career and have been
caught the imaging cloud decided to
pursue the commercial career in this
field having worked for a few companies
sign microscopy products dr. well join
under technology in 2009 since then he
hasn't into the role of product manager
for microscopy systems focusing on
product development applications
delivering delivery to market and
support please join me in welcoming dr.
Wilde thanks Julian thank you very much
for the introduction so good morning oh
good afternoon depending on where you
are I guess in the world watching this I
think early morning for some of you on
the west coast so this is going to be a
primarily an educational presentation
though I I you will note that I'm from
and also from a commercial company but
I'll maintain an educational aspect as
much as I can and today actually before
I start what I'd like to do is there is
there's a poll available for you to
please if you can do so and have the
time answer some questions during the
course of the presentation this helps us
really primarily in our looking at what
the market is doing that helps us really
address what might be out there and how
we can develop our products and what
avenues in the future so by knowing how
many of you are using this technique
looking it interested in optogenetic for
example we can try and look to see an
address that market even better okay so
my talk today is going to be on the
benefits of combining optogenetics with
microscopy and electrophysiology and
obviously focusing in this respect on
your
science so back in 1999 and the cover
lecture series Creek stressed the
importance of combining to the
techniques of molecular biology and
neuroscience and his argument was that
to understand a complex biological
system want us to be able to interfere
with it both precisely and delicately
probably at all levels but especially at
the cellular and molecular level and
this was in order to obtain as much
information in detail as we can about a
complex I guess complex networks and for
example it as in the case of euro
science so as I so focusing on
optogenetics an opto physiology so what
are the goals of optogenetics
optogenetics primarily is designed or
the aim is to preserve cells and or
signaling pathways with precise control
in the spatial and temporal domains
while sups of physiology is more about
less about perturbation but more about
observing cells or intercellular
signaling events in real time using
optical probes allowing for a macular
the macroscale imaging of cells or
networks and as I said this is primarily
without perturbation so for example
recording voltages or electrical
transients without for example using
electrodes which are invasive so very
common optical stimulation techniques
currently that many of you may be aware
of would be the likes of photo bleaching
so that's a four essence recovery after
photobleaching whereby you'd be looking
at for example the dynamics of proteins
within a cell or the turnover of
proteins within a cell proteins that
you've labeled fluorescently
photoactivation and photo conversion are
both similar techniques again photo
let's labeling a protein of interest
with a with a green or red fluorescent
protein for example and then either
switching them off for converting them
from one color to another again to help
you understand the dynamics of proteins
that you're interested in within
cellular models and then finally there's
another form here uncaging so this for
example would be
to take transmitter such as glutamate or
an intercellular signaling molecule such
as calcium caging it in a compound being
able to introduce that into a cell in a
cage dinner to form and then targeting
that case compound with light to release
it in a very controlled and localized
way within a cell to better understand
how that compound how that molecule for
example works within sub-regions of a
cell and these are probably techniques
that you're already fairly familiar with
they're fairly common these days well
precisely what is optogenetics so it was
first defined what made was the first
two fibers defined by mizen back in 2009
the branch of biotin ranted
biotechnology which combines genetic
engineering with optics to observe a
controller function of genetically
targeted groups of cells with light
often in the intact animal and basically
these are genetic tools that will allow
you to express opsins which are
light-sensitive proteins in for example
a membrane of cells and then use
specific wavelengths of light which
activate the opsin and then when the ops
in itself undergoes a conformational
change then that will trigger a cellular
response this could be opening of
channels or it could be for example the
activation of a secondary messenger
system such as cyclic a and B now opsins
are basically a light-activated proteins
that are encoded by the opsin gene it is
essentially that they're most commonly a
group of seven transmembrane domains
that are like responsive and there are
two types of opsins actually what i
should say is there's a retinal element
to these trans there's a wrestle
elements to the transmembrane domains
which i'll show you on the next slide so
the retinal + op singh brings us to the
name rhodopsin there are two types
primarily at the moment of the the
options there's microbial options which
are typically from poker
yachts and algae and fungi and then as a
type to the animal opsins from higher
eukaryotes and they are typically
encoding g-protein coupled receptors so
this is one that this was one of the
first read opsins to be categorized and
used this is channelrhodopsin and it's
from the green algae and what you can
see here are the seven transmembrane
domains one of which here you can see in
this region is the all trans retinal
this is the element that's sensitive to
light and when light of a certain
wavelength and that wave length can vary
depending on the opsin when light hits
that it undergoes a conformational
change in this case it would open the
poor within a membrane and announced
across it and Kyle disrupts lab at
Stanford did the first work with
channelrhodopsin in mammalian neurons so
this is just an example of their pup of
a publication from Boyden Boylan's lab
using channelrhodopsin i'm not going to
go through every single point on this
slide but first of all for most if we
look at that they're obviously looking
here in a their imaging they're able to
image the neuron that they're interested
in and therefore want to stimulate with
light so they'll be recording from the
from the neuron and looking for an
action potential for shifting potential
so what you can see here in B and I'll
try and bring up an arrow here so here
in B you can see that the black line the
black straight line that you can see is
when the cell is that the neurons are
illuminated and you can see that during
illumination there's a depolarization of
the cell if you look across to see you
can extrapolate that further and you can
see that if you do a repeat pulse of
light you get a repeat in electrical
activity
so it's quite a powerful way of being
able to mimic for example the cell
signaling that the signaling that you
would have in a neuron or in your own
network so going back to the different
rhodopsins that you tie the different
options that you have you can see that
different options have different
properties so in the case of
channelrhodopsin it's a channel pore
that allows sodium to pass through it
you have the Hale rhodopsin which is a
chlorine then you have the bacterial
adoptions here which are hydrogen ions
and then the opto XR options which are
more linked to secondary messenger
systems like ip3 cyclic anp etc and
there's a whole family of these and
there there's sort of new ones being
discovered and utilized all the time so
pretty much over time that if you look
around this likely to be a tool an
option that's relevant to your research
and what it is you're wanting to look at
so in order to bring up to genetics and
physiology to your research first and
foremost you want to find a
light-sensitive probe that addresses
your research question so choose an
option that is compatible with what it
is you wanting to resit look into and
then you need the ability to genetically
target that probe into your specimen and
then ultimately then you obviously going
to want an optical source and a means of
targeting the light to your specimen and
to target it at a level that's relevant
to the if you like the resolution set
cellular or otherwise resolution of what
you're aiming to to try and disseminate
in your sample and depending on your
research your tool may be something
quite a macroscopic if you like in a
form of behavioral assays or it could be
something more specific by combining
with electrophysiology equipment or
simply having it as an additional tool
to imaging at the level of a microscope
so looking at the these sort of cellular
level if you like using imaging
equipment on a microscope you could
combine optogenetics with any three any
one of these three applications
so I'm going to start with an example of
how you can use targeted light it under
a microscope I have to confess at this
first paper is not specifically neuronal
but it is a very good example of how you
can use light to target your samples to
try to target your you're like sensitive
probe so this group from Blatter's lab
here this group we're looking to
characterize if you like a model so they
could look into calcium activity and
behavior in muscle contraction so first
and foremost they wanted to establish
that they could use a device that could
target light at a resolution at end at a
cellular level that was relevant to the
answers that they wanted to ask of their
model so not quite sure what's happened
to the content of that slide there with
me a moment okay we go right so and so
if we look at this slide here the first
row if you look at the top here a in the
first picture what we have here is we
have the lab with a group has basically
taken fluorescein in a liquid form on on
a microscope slide they've taken
fluorescein they've withered it with
their device which in this case is a DMD
device they base it that this is the
device on their microscope that they're
going to use to target their light that
device is able to draw a pattern that is
writing out the letter c a2 plus for
calcium and then they can target the
fluorescein they can put with four or
five nanometers they've basically
bleached the word calcium into their
fluorescing blob on this on this slide
if you look to the next sequence of four
here what we have is we have caged
calcium and that case calcium is in a in
a in a media and a mixture of the flu or
four which is obviously sensitive to
calcium floor for will will fluoresce
put went when it
binds to it and so what again they've
done here is they've written the words
the latter CA for calcium using their
the device they're going to target the
light with and then they're able to
engage the calcium and for a brief
moment you can see the letter CA in the
fluorescent blob and then not
surprisingly it diffuses then over time
so they're now taking this ability to
create very discrete areas of
illumination and they're now targeting
in this experiment muscle cells so
they're not targeting the whole muscle
cell they're targeting to discrete
regions in be in the second row here the
image of the slide i should say they're
talking in two very discrete regions of
light and what you can see is you get a
subsequent contraction of the whole
muscle fiber and this model generally
speaking there was a lot more obviously
to this paper than this but this model
was demonstrating the fact that you
could stimulate muscle contraction
through very discrete areas of
stimulation or calcium release and that
they were able to then look at
calcium-induced calcium release in their
model and try and disseminate its
behavior further so that gives you an
idea of the kind of detail that you can
achieve targeting light at these
light-sensitive probes using microscopy
so this is another good example now
we're moving back to the more familiar
world of neuroscience so here we have
the group here of from the pier maui lee
ada lab and mat-su Valley lab at the
incident that Pasteur Institute in
France and this group are very
interested in in these are slice
preparations that they're using and
they're interested in mapping neuronal
networks as quickly as possible before
the slice dies so what they are here is
they they're able to optically stimulate
the the mitral cells and basically
elicit an inhibitory postsynaptic
current in the mitral cells so they're
optically stimulating if you look at a
you see where the optical optical
simulation is of the mitral cell and
then they're recording upstream on a
granule cell and then they're looking to
see how that affects their the
electrophysiology of their this
particular network here and what they're
looking to do is as quickly as possible
and you can see this grids if you look
in the image where be and you can see
this grid they're able to very quickly
stimulate each one of these squares of
the grid in sequence and map where they
hit a cell movement a mitral cell where
they hid it and therefore when they are
successful in stimulating what effect
that is having the electrical recording
further downstream so for example if you
look now at see you can see actually
sorry and B you've got a yellow and an
orange square if you look at c you can
see that when they hit the yellow square
and there's a neuron mitral cell in
there then hit the yellow square they
get a nice synaptic earth they get a
nice response from their elected
recording electrode but the neighboring
square they get no response at all so
this way they're able to map very
efficiently there there neuronal network
within this within a slice culture
before the slice dice and there's high
throughput is of great benefit for their
work so so that was an example the
previous slide was example of where
they're using channelrhodopsin I didn't
say that actually so that was
channelrhodopsin so that's looking at
opening pause in the membrane for
excitation of cells now we're moving on
to an option which is more which is
associated the secondary messenger
system so this is from the gout am lab
so what these this lab is doing is
they're interested in looking at if they
stimulate g-protein coupled receptors on
new rights whether they can initiate new
right initiation and extension so what
the group of doing here is they've got
cells that are expressing op singh with
em cherry so if you so if we rather look
at the top of the slide if you look at
the let me see if I can pull up an arrow
again
so if you look at here where my arrows
pointing so these are basically opsin
genetically modified opsin with g couple
protein receptor characteristics
combined with them cherry so they can
visualize the cell so that's the red
color and what they're going to do is
they're going to be there imaging the
cell in red and then they're going to be
using a very discreet region exciting
with with with light in order to try and
stimulate the opsin the g cup of protein
opsin so if you look at the this first
trip here and me you have your cell what
they're doing is the little yellow boxes
where they're targeting their light to
stimulate the ops in and you can see
that over time as they stimulate that
that region with light you can see that
the cell is is starting to extend
getting you right extension towards the
stimulation of the light stimulation
where it's being targeted and over time
you're getting a new right formation and
in rhody this is looking at the actin in
a similar kind of experiment so here
again they're stimulating just at the
edge of the in order to stimulate the
new right formation and then over time
you can see not not only is the new
right formation occurring but also
you're getting active formation as well
to support the permanent formation of
that new right so it's quite a powerful
tool to be able to use these options
with such a discreet way of illuminating
your sample so i'm sure has new a
scientist most of you are familiar with
the hippocampus it's a popular part of
the brain with which to work because it
is such a nice discrete network of
neurons and it's also defined by very
eat discrete regions that are easily
targeted such as the dentate gyrus so
that the for those of you don't know the
the flow if you like of the
the network is from the dentate gyrus
through the ca3 and then round through
to the ca1 and there's a nice network of
neurons here both excitatory and
inhibitory that people like to try and
work with to understand communication
between neurons populations of different
types the challenge has always been up
until fairly recently before
optogenetics was really a viable tool
the only way really to investigate
networks within the hippocampus we're
obviously through electrical recording
but then if you wanted to try and
stimulate nerve cells in a particular
way you are typically having to resort
to things like iontophoretic for example
application of the neurotransmitters and
excitatory molecule say such as
glutamate for example but in in applying
transmitters or chemicals in this way it
was impossible to get discreet
simulation of a single nerve cell you'd
always typically get also a population
of cells being triggered which makes
disseminating a neuronal network and
specific connections very hard to do so
what we can do is now use targeted
lights I let me go back a slide there so
what we can do now instead of using
chemicals adding chemicals which are
hard to target we can actually just
having genetically modified the sample
the organ that's over the model that we
want to do so let's say mouse in this
case having genetically modified the
neurons of interest then we're able to
target those with light so this is a
good example of how we can improve
targeting of lights to get nice discreet
neuronal responses so if you look at the
slide here and I'll bring up another
arrow keeps collapsing sorry about that
so I'm just trying to get my arrow okay
so if you if you look here in the first
up here where my arrow is so you can see
this is a this is a model whereby it is
it is genetically modified so that we
have options expressed but the light
stimulation wasn't particularly discreet
it was it was a regional stimulation so
the consequence is that you have
depolarization but you can see that it's
a it's a multi synaptic response there
isn't a single discrete action potential
here but if you look below this then it
is possible with with some with the
right light source with the right
hardware in order it is possible to
actually discreetly excite a single
neuron and that's really what a lot of
people are aiming for for some of their
to understand some of their circuits and
to be able to dissect complex Nero
neural circuits so how might we target
our light so there's a mean what a
common way to target light as I'm going
to start with the Galvan based system so
I have a second bullet point down here a
common way to target light is Galvan
basis that we two mirrors Galvan mirrors
that are in XY that can scan across a
field these are quite commonly used in
point scanning confocal for example but
can be used on other systems these are
these are great however they're
typically quite how they're typically is
with higher power densities such as with
lasers as light sources and they're good
but they're more typically used for
photobleaching of those kind of
experiments typically for what for
optogenetics and particularly the
neuronal work galvin based systems
aren't that ideal because of the way
they scan this of a pixel at a time we
need something that's faster more
instantaneous and ideally we need
something that isn't scanning we need
something that can maybe target more
than one region in a single shot
particularly when you're looking at
complex neuronal networks so so as it
happens and all has hardware that does
this and this would be using
DMD digital micromirror device based
systems and here we will do here we can
achieve simultaneous multi-region
illumination and that will be the focus
of the hardware today just to put you
just to give you an idea of how we're
actually targeting this elimination and
then we'll go on to some more
applications so so the DMD was it was
actually came out of the came out of
more out of the television industry if
you like I guess and now is more
commonly used in sort of the film
industry i should say for motion
pictures and it was it's now more
compost commonly used in projectors that
use oxy for presentations and Hornbeck
at the age of 71 picked up an award for
developing the DMD obviously it's gone
to be used in many different
applications outside of the film
industry since then but it basically
allows us to patent light so what what
what what is it at a salon in more
detail with DMD the DMV is basically an
array of Mike Ramirez thousands of micro
Mike Ramirez that basically tilt on or
off you can control the angle of tilt
but is basically an on or off device but
by having these houses and Mike Ramirez
you're able to project patterns so if
you can using software define a pattern
then you can have the micromirrors
transmit that pattern onto you know in
the case of a projector onto a screen in
the case of microscopy you can have that
pattern projected through the through
the objective onto your sample so you
can see here in the bottom right of this
slide that we're able to project strips
of light onto this onto this cell these
are this is photo activating gfp so you
can see very discreet strips of
activated gfp so that you can actually
visualize the actin in the cell and then
you can then go on to see which way
which which direction the acting is
flowing so how what forms that DMD so
take and how can how can it
with a microscope so this happens to be
our device call it mosaic 3 the DMD
digital mirror device resides in the
head of the of the instrument which is
here just wear my arrow is that is
coupled to a larger optical component on
the left here we have a light input
which can either be lasers or LEDs this
is this is the illumination sources as
the light source is projected onto the
DMD and then a DMD with it with its
pattern that's been defined through
software the pattern then is projected
down through the optical system into the
microscope to give you a better idea of
where this fits in terms of a microscope
I'll move on to this slide so we can
start with your the base of your
microscope you can add the mosaic
devices of the MD device in between your
microscope and your eye pieces and then
you can simply have a camera and you're
good to go and then basically obviously
then you need a pc and a workstation you
need a means of being able to target the
light so the camera offers to two
opportunities that offers jobs to the
opportunity to image your sample but
also it gives the ability for to
calibrate the DMV device so that it
knows where to target and patterns that
you generate using the software
interface so so the DMD brings together
as I said it requires it requires a
camera because the camera is required in
order to calibrate the DMV and any
combination with the DMD you would have
software that is capable of accepting
patterns that you create masks and then
those masks can be uploaded onto the
memory of the D of the device and then
the device can can run through those
patterns
so before we move on to I guess more
application data and actually how it
might work first and foremost obviously
you need to choose your light source the
DMV still requires a source of light the
the options are typically need absolute
if you like a peak current of around
about 10 million watts per millimeter
square door or less than i should say up
to 10 millimeter 10 million watts per
millimeter squared and leds are
perfectly powerful in combination with
the DMD device for this and LEDs are
actually favored quite a lot by people
using DMD devices actually generally
optogenetics generally because of the
speed that they can be switched on and
off especially in neuroscience you know
the physiology of nerve cells is very
fast milliseconds or less and so you
need a light source that's obviously
going to work at those of those speeds
as well so LEDs are good for this this
this is a this is that the patter this
is a pattern that's generated to
basically the DMV here is got this
pattern loaded onto it so this just is
just a test pattern and that test
pattern is basically now projected
through the microscope on to a mirror
slide and the camera is capturing the
pattern that you're seeing here so this
just gives you an idea of the complexity
of the pattern that the DMD can project
not surprisingly it's complex is no
different to the projector in that sense
and it also gives you an idea of how
finally you can you can go in terms of
the pattern that you can actually
achieve so we're going down to fairly
small line pairs that small numbers of
line pairs per millimeter here so I mean
we're not diffraction limited but we're
getting close close to that end so we
are able to through this where I are
able to stimulate something as discreet
as a single cell or even the dendrite of
a neuron and not only is is it able a
capable of doing black and white images
with
also sorry the movies not going to play
here I've realized but also it we can do
great we can do gray level gray scaling
with it as well and we can do gray
scaling simply by dithering some mirrors
over a period of over a period of times
as possible to do you know 8-bits
16-bits etc great gray scaling so that
you can actually have doing this you can
achieve very specific light dose
responses and you can actually have
different you can have different regions
in the same pattern with different light
intensities which might be relevant to
your model that you're looking at again
sadly these movies aren't going to play
either this was just going to give you
an idea of the kind of patterns that you
can generate you can either you can
generate patent sequentially
simultaneously obviously and then
equally on the right there you can do
cumulative patterns as I say the movies
aren't going to play but for example if
you look at the cumulative one you could
imagine that this was a series of
neuronal cell bodies or bitter party of
dem dendritic processes that we're
discretely stimulating and you could you
could stimulate those in different
combinations in order to establish what
the downstream effect might be so let's
go back to a more practical situation
here in terms of combining the the
optogenetics with electrophysiology so
so far I've actually mentioned when you
really mentioned the use of up to
genetics in terms of stimulation of
excitation of opening channels for
example equally there are genetically
modified options out there that are not
only capable of stimulation but also of
inhibition so you might be able to some
will stimulate let's say 460 nanometers
whereas others will be inhibited let's
say at 7 40 nanometers of wavelengths of
light and therefore you may choose in
your neuronal model to have some cells
that are
suitable and in some cells you can most
you can distinctly inhibit so if you can
imagine a time experiment a time for
some experiment combining with
electrophysiology recording at the
bottom here you'd want to record for a
period of time to get a baseline
measurement and then you might want to
alternate 300 milliseconds of excitation
of the particular cell followed by or
dendrite identity process followed by
five milliseconds of inhibition for the
by 300 milliseconds of excitation etc
and then look at your
electrophysiological recordings as a
consequence of that interaction now you
can you can look at that in combination
with your electrophysiology rig so if
you're an electrophysiologist then you
can combine you're typically going to
have a digi data some form of device
that is a pulse pulse generator if you
like to combine your lecture physiology
electrophysiological work with
stimulating or interacting with other
bits of hardware so in this case it's
possible to load so let's start with the
mosaic in the in the top left in the top
right there is you would start for
example by loading a series of patterns
illumination patterns onto the memory of
the mosaic device you would then have
that hooked up to an external trigger so
that you can stimulate so that you can
toy trigger the activation of those
patterns as as and when you want to in
relation to your electrophysiology run
and then equally so you can you will
also need to be able to trigger the LED
light source to alternate between your
short wavelengths and your long
wavelength for excitation and inhibition
and that led is obviously then hooked up
as a light source to the mosaic 3 and so
if you look in the image at the bottom
right here you can see that we have an
experiment here where we're region one
which is the inhibitory is distinctly
focused on the cell body whereas region
2 is distinctly focused on the process
and we can
to that level of resolution in terms of
targeting the light and then this is the
this is the software interface that we
would use to create the pattern in the
first place so we're able to generate
our regions of interest we can then
upload that hatton onto the mosaic we
can choose whether that's going to be a
sequential pattern or a cumulative or a
or a simultaneous and we can load those
on to the to the mosaic and then we can
have them SAT there waiting to be called
off every time a TTL signal comes
through from the electrophysiology rig
and then if you're using something like
clamp x software then you're able to
generate you're able to combine that
mosaic activation that's the mosaic
sequence in with your with your
electrophysiology recording and have
everything time in perfectly so you can
get a good complex well timed experiment
out of out of combining the two sets of
hardware so this I'm not going I'm not
going to dwell on the slide but this
would be a typical example of the
interface and the clamp X and the digi
data control in order to set up an
experiment that could place the current
through changing the different
wavelengths on the LED as well as
running through the patterns so so those
that starts using optogenetics in
combination with electrophysiology but
increasingly now people are moving to
more rather than using electrophysiology
necessarily as the as the recording
mechanism they're using more sort of up
to physiology techniques so these are
these are typically the fluorescent
probes the russell sensitive the thrust
dyes that are sensitive to various
conditions changes in conditions so for
example we have the genetically encoded
voltage indicators
or voltage sensitive throat
voltage-sensitive thrustin proteins so
there are a range of those so that it's
rather than using electrophysiology to
record changes in electrical activity
then we have these present proteins that
will that will change in intensity in
response to a change in voltage so this
is a much this is a much less invasive
way of recording from cells and actually
does mean that you can record purely
using imaging techniques as opposed to
having additional Hardware equally there
are there up there a whole range of
these various probes are the sensitive
to different things so from the
Augustine lab here we have clammy Liam
so this is a this is a fluorescent
protein that is sensitive to chlorine
when it interacts with chlorine it
undergoes a conformational change that
gives them out of threat signal there
are ph-sensitive forms of ph-sensitive
probes there are the keys the calcium
indicators of these approps that change
in intensity when calcium binds to them
equally you have limit for temperature
changes and also transmitter release of
the signal is er a a glutamate sensitive
protein here so sadly this movie is not
going to play either so I'm going to
have to try and explain this to you so
this is out of the lab of renegade us
here in Texas so they're using a calcium
sensor the the G camp so this is a
present for essence calcium sensitive
sensor and they're combining this with
channelrhodopsin so they're looking here
at C elegans they're looking at the
Petrak de muscle so this is the sex
organ of the C elegans and they're
looking at the fuel and more
specifically the protractor muscles so
if I with the
aid of some arrows with my way through
this so if you look to the green the
green highlighted area here near my
arrow so there's a challenge in this
experiment in that they want to record
the calcium response using G camp this
requires being able to excite at 400 ran
about 488 nanometers so they need they
need 488 nanometers to to excite and
record the calcium response from the G
camp so that's the first arrow so I just
need to get my second arrow but over
here near the red box they want to
stimulate nerve cells which have the
channelrhodopsin in now channelrhodopsin
is also stimulated at around about 400
was actually 460 nanometers but it can
be stimulated at the same wavelength
that is required to image the g camp so
the challenge here is that obviously
they can't they can't image the whole
field for g camp because they'll also
stimulate the channelrhodopsin at the
same time so one of the advantages of
having a DMV based system is that the
group is able to discreetly image the g
camp by setting up a region of interest
on the DMD that is constantly active and
therefore able to discreetly excite an
image that the area the muscle
protractors took the protractor muscle
in green so they're able to illuminate
that area constantly whilst not
stimulating the channelrhodopsin further
upstream where the nerves at work where
the nerve cells are they can run the
experiment and then when they're ready
they can discreetly stimulate the where
the red boxes they can discreetly
stimulate the nerve cells there by
hitting them with 460 nanometers of
light and then what will happen is that
like you can't see this what happens is
when they do it excites that redbox what
they see it
they see an increase in signal in green
signal intensity so the green intensity
to the left that goes brighter increases
in intensity and the muscle contract and
then when they stake when they stop
stimulating the redbox with light you
see the intensity fall away and the
muscle relaxants and then this is this
is a this is a example of using in this
case it's not calcium sensitive it's a
voltage sensitive so George Augustine's
group again they have been out there
able to combine micromirror based
optogenetic photo stimulation with
voltage-sensitive dye imaging so so here
you can see this is purely all obviously
now all based on imaging there's no
electrophysiology so what they're doing
is they have their imaging neuronal
population here and they're looking at
the inter neurons and they're able to
use a voltage-sensitive dye imaging
they're able to record a the electrical
activity through imaging rather than
through electrophysiology
nearly at the end now this last last
last one or two slides so this is
another example here of looking at
voltage using voltage-sensitive dies so
here we're looking to stimulate
different regions so i should say record
from different regions having stimulated
a large area so look at in a figure a so
we're looking at stimulating different
areas within the we got the purkinje
cell layer the molecular layer and the
granule cell layer and we're looking
lately stimulating this region of brain
recording from those areas and you can
see next to this you can see that that
the that area one the granule cell layer
isn't responsive to the elimination
whereas the other two layers where and
you're able to actually in the if you
look at be the four images there 8.8 11
19.8 and eighty three point six
millimeter milliseconds this is
basically if you like a color it's a
color map of the response you can get an
idea of not just where the voltage
response is but also the extent of that
response and i think in order to make
sure we leave type of questions that's
just another example so i'm going to
skip through this why suppose actually
i'll quickly cover it so this is a good
example of showing you how you can use
the DMV to actually be very discreet and
where you're trying to target so if you
look at a in the top left here for my
arrow again so you can see here that the
group here are interested in mapping
differently see these little boxes
mapping very discreet dendritic
processes and then looking to see what
that what that does in terms of response
and also they're playing with light
doses as well
so if you look over to D at the far end
what they've done here is they're trying
increasing light doses the lines are
connecting neurons neurons of a similar
so the same neuron so they're looking at
responses from the same neurons but at
different light doses so different
intensities of light and you can see
that you can control they can control
the level of activity according to the
amount of light that they're eliminating
the missiles with to get a light dose
response curve in terms of voltage
activity or electrical activity from
those cells so it's quite a powerful way
of disseminating your neuronal networks
so so basically obviously what I've
hopefully managed to convey is the power
that you know that we now have combining
optogenetics with neuroscience and
having the ability with the right
technology to very discreetly stimulate
specific neurons or groups of neurons or
even dendritic branches you're able to
disseminate to a high degree of detail
you're able to pull apart networks and
and responses neuronal responses a court
using these tools both targeting lights
but also tools that can sense things
like voltage changes for example and
calcium changes so that concludes my
presentation and thank you for spending
time with me this afternoon and I will
take some questions and if there are
some questions that the QA area
thank you dr. al for that informative
presentation so it is time to the Q&A
and if you have a question you'd like to
ask your speaker please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button will answer as many
questions as you have time for let's get
started our first question is how do you
make sure that only one channel is
activated by targeting CH are two okay
so so announced that would also I run an
echo okay so so the ability to activate
a single channel is unlikely so my
apologies if I've conveyed that it can
be done at the single-channel level it
will obviously be a population of
channels within a region so we can get
we were able to simulate let's say down
to the dendritic branch level but we
certainly don't have the resolution here
optically in this system to be able to
stimulate a single channel so this would
be this would be stimulating a
population of channels basically within
an area of a cell
the next question does the creation of
GPCRs link to behavior via chemotaxis
receive the creation of GPCRs that link
photo taxes to the responses measured in
the context of optogenetics microscopy
and electrophysiology okay right okay hi
so I must confess that question was so
long that I haven't followed it what I
need to do is try and find out Oh tagged
right sorry just trying to find the
question so I can see it there we go
thank you okay so does the creation of
GPCRs linked to behavior Viking the
taxes why I can just proceed the
creation of GPCRs let link phototaxis to
the response is measured in the context
now I do apologize I am NOT following
that question fully in order to answer
it so what I'm going to do is I'm
assuming I have the opportunity to
answer this answer questions afterwards
more completely so I think if you'll
forgive me I'm going to answer that one
later depends because I need to probably
give it more thought than I can give it
just this now so i will i will come back
and answer that question but I'll do it
in writing if that's okay
the next question how does the empty
class Pacific side illumination I
understand the principle but not how it
happens so specific site of it so
basically so that's the DMD as I
explained as a series of micro micro
mirrors so what we do is we can we can
basically use software to define which
of those micromirrors or well which
which then which of those Mike Ramirez
and how many of those Mike Ramirez
switch on when those Mike Ramirez flip
to switch on they will then reflect the
light from the light source they'll
reflect that light down through the
optical system through the objective
onto your sample so so basically we
create a we create a pattern a region
using software that dictates which Mike
Ramirez are switched on and then the
pattern of Mike Ramirez that are
switched on and then projected onto your
sample your sample is obviously well in
this case is under an objective and so
we're able to target quite specifically
that light to wherever it is on your
target what we will have done previously
is calibrate that DMV so so within
within the within the field of field of
view of your camera we can we can
associate a pixel of the DMD to a pixel
of the camera and by doing that we can
map a pattern very specifically from the
DMD through to the sample itself I hope
that explains that for you great the
next question is is there an optimal
spectral range for the use of DMD system
where it worked well with nir light as
well okay so um there is an optical
there is an optimal spectral range
we do have it does go up it does
actually go up into the NIR it lassie
also active specifically and I ask that
at that end yes we do have some we do
have some people using it up at the NIR
end of the spectrum it does it does drop
off round about 800 nanometers if I
remember correctly but it to the tails
off but certainly if you wanted to find
out more we could give you more
specifics it's also the case that it can
tend to be optimal for very specific
wavelengths in that in within that
spectrum as well so so we would need to
know I guess the type of wavelength
around which kind of wavelength you're
looking to to to image but certainly
we've got people using it up up at that
end of the range if you just let us know
what it is you're specifically
interested in we can check to see if
it's if it's useful at that end for you
what are the different types of our sins
and humans that can be useful for up to
genetic study okay that's probably out
of the realms of my knowledge yeah I'm
sorry I'm so in that sense I'm not going
to be much help to hear because I'm not
I'm not really in the research field of
that particularly in that so I'm going
to have to say I'm not able to answer
that question myself so my apologies for
that okay is there any effect caused by
changing the intensity of optical
simulations because the last paper
actually the publication that I showed
you their cover that so yes you can
actually do lights dose response curve
so you as you can as you increase the
intensity you can see an increase in
let's say in the case of neurons you can
see an increase in elect
call activity whether that be looking a
greater voltage deeper depolarization or
if you're looking at networks that might
be a bigger neuronal population response
for example so yes intensity definitely
plays a role in the kind of response
that you might get okay we're almost out
of time so this will have to be our last
question can you apply describe out of
genetics methods to record activity from
your own from neurons in vivo can you
describe da genetics methods recorded
vivo um II yes I'm well yes so so a lot
a lot of the optogenetics work is
currently being done in in vivo so if
I'd probably the probably point of
majority or goodness I not majority but
a good high percentage of odd genetic
methods are used in vivo so that would
be using fibers fiber optic and
delivering laser light to fairly
discrete regions for example of the
brain in vivo I guess it would be
possible to apply this to an inch of
vital model if you're thinking if you're
asking more in relation to a combining
with microscopy so yes it wouldn't be
possible with some consideration and
making you know with some consideration
it probably would be possible to add to
apply the DMD method in in inner
intravital method intravital way using
microscopy
alright well thank you once again dr. al
I would also like to thank our sponsor
and our technology for making today's
educational webcast possible so before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing until September 2016
you are receiving email from laverton in
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today too then that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye